well first of all we recognize that this
is a stressful time for British tourists
who are on the ground in Sharm el-sheikh
but I emphasize that we haven't changed
our threat rating for the resort of
Sharm el-sheikh itself this is
specifically an aviation issue so work
with your tour operator talk to your
tour operator representative they the
Egyptian government the British
government are working together our
aviation experts are on the ground our
security experts are on the ground we
will have arrangements in place to bring
people home safely at the end of their
holidays there's no need for people to
leave ahead of schedule unless they wish
to if anybody wishes to leave early we
expect the airlines will arrange to
bring them back early without surcharge
but there is no threat to them in their
in their hotels going about their normal
business in Sharm el-sheikh and we be
assured that we will not allow any UK
bound aircraft to take off from Sharm
el-sheikh until we are absolutely
certain that it is safe for it to do so
and have you got British military
aircraft landing in sharm airport and if
so why are they there if there are
British I'm not aware that there are any
British military aircraft on the ground
if there are it will own they will only
be there in a capacity of ferrying
people out we've had experts going out
from the UK aviation security experts
and others and they are they we've
obviously wanted to get them into Sharm
el-sheikh as quickly as possible i know
a lot of people were driving down
overnight from cairo it may be that some
have come in by non non scheduled
flights into sharp a lot but there's a
possibility that british aircraft could
be used to ferry holidaymakers out if
required if you're asking about the
possible use of military aircraft
there's no reason to think that that
will be necessary as we saw in the
aftermath of the sous attacks that the
tour operators actually are the ones
that have the capacity to organize this
they have access to huge numbers of
aircraft and seats they're very well
organized they are geared up to deal
with this kind of issue when it arises
and we would expect the tour operators
to be able to manage all the capacity
that's needed to bring people out from
Sharm el-sheikh using regular tour
operator flights it's just that they
will in the short term they will fly out
empty in order to bring ample back
Foreign Secretary your intelligence
wherever you've gleaned it from
obviously the Egyptians are saying you
should wait for the results of the
investigation though they can't be that
outrageous tour they wouldn't allow you
to go into their Airport and rejigged
security or give you a view of security
but shouldn't you be sharing that
intelligence with other nations I mean I
see today I'm just looking at their
plans the Russians are still flying in a
night for instance who do you share that
intelligence with or is that just for
our eyes only well I said I said earlier
that this with the decisions we've made
are based on a review of all the
information that's available to us now
some of that information is sensitive
intelligence and I can't talk about
sensitive intelligence and obviously
there are restrictions on how we can
make that available what we do do though
is share our conclusions with all our
partners and I expect during the course
of today you'll see other partners
reviewing the situation looking at the
information picture as we have done and
and reaching conclusions night you use
that word conclusions is it your
conclusion and can you share that with
us that Isis is behind this well i still
sign i have claimed responsibility for
bringing down the the russian aircraft
they did that straight away after the
crash we've looked at the whole
information picture including that claim
but of course lots of other bits of
information as well and concluded that
there is a significant possibility I
can't put it stronger than that of
course as you said earlier there will
eventually be a conclusive finding on
this when the investigation is complete
the wreckage has all been collected yeah
but examine the meantime they must you
must believe that that is a credible
claim or you wouldn't be doing what
you're doing we believe there's a
possibility that the aircraft could have
been brought down by an explosive device
on board we can't wait for the outcome
of the inquiry which will look at all
the wreckage and everything we've got to
take action now because large numbers of
British tourists are flying in and out
of Sharm el-sheikh three and a half
thousand British tourists would do to go
out to sharm today and in those
circumstances we've had to make a
decision and we have to err on the side
of caution because whenever there is a
threat to British lives the safety of
British nationals we will always act
even though we recognize that creates
disruption and inconvenience it creates
an impact on the Egyptian tourist
economy we have to act where there's a
threat a credible threat to British
nationals and we've done so so I get
that but for the people and we've been
speaking to holidaymakers this morning I
mean they're genuinely left in the lurch
some people the holiday is coming to an
end and that's it they don't have the
money they don't have the resources
they've got to go and sit in the airport
at do you have any sort of rough time
scale as to how long this flight ban on
curfew will last yet yes there's two
stages to this process so we're working
with the airlines and the Egyptian
authorities now to put in place
emergency short-term measures that will
allow us to safely bring back the
British tourists who are there in sharm
we expect those to be in operation by
tomorrow so that people whose flights
were due out yesterday or today should
start to move out tomorrow and those
emergency measures will remain in place
as we bring out the British tourists to
a currently in Sharm el-sheikh over the
next week or 10 days beyond that we need
to work with the Egyptians and the
airline's to put in place sustainable
routine measures that will allow us to
resume normal flying now I can't tell
you whether that will be days weeks or
months that depends on what we find on
the ground when the detailed work is
carried out on what the Egyptian
authorities are willing and able to do
on what demands the airlines
make so that's the second stage of the
process and we very much hope that it
will be possible hopefully before the
christmas new year rush to declare sharm
el-sheikh safe and to start to resume
normal flight operations between the UK
and charm so despite what the Egyptians
are saying about their airport security
you'll find the contrary you'll find
that it needed to be shored up well
clearly as I've said that we believe
there's a significant possibility that
an explosive device was on board the
Russian plane and responsible for its
crash if that has happened something has
gone wrong somewhere clear that's not
supposed to happen and therefore since
if we believe there's a significant
possibility that that happened we have
to look to airline and airport security
processes to see how that could have
happened so just to reiterate
repatriation plans are there if needed
and there is a significant possibility
you believe that Isis was behind this a
significant possibility that there was
an explosive device on the plane Isis
have claimed responsibility for the
downing of the aircraft that's a matter
of public record and in terms of
repatriation the airlines the tour
operators expect to be able to bring
everybody out on their originally
scheduled departures start from tomorrow
on their originally scheduled departures
unless people want to leave early and we
expect the airlines will make special
arrangements for anybody who doesn't
feel comfortable in sharm who wants to
come out early to do so foreign
secretary appreciate your time and your
clarification of things this morning
thank you very much she'd